- I'm sure you all saw Adam perform
at the Emmy Awards last month.
It was incredible.
But here's the funny part of it
is you were under attack for like,
first of all, the greatest thing ever.
- I was under attack, guys.
I was attacked!
Well, they, Variety
said that I lip synced.
- Which, by the way, just
means you're that bad ass.
- Well, thank you for that.
But I sang, I sang that.
And I was pretty bummed.
- No, I know, that's
happened to me before,
and I was like, I wanted to
call this lady named Lisa.
- I feel like any real
singer would have been like,
oh no, he sang that, you could tell.
- Yeah, no, no, but
that's what I'm saying,
it was actually a good thing.
Like I got so mad about
it when it happened to me
like years ago.
'Cause I was like, I just
worked my tail off on stage.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- And somebody said that.
And then everybody was like,
well maybe it just
means you did it so well
that people thought it had to have been.
- By the way, if I'm
ever asked to do anything
like that again, I'm more
than happy to lip sync.
That would take away
like all the pressure.
- Oh my gosh, right, and running around.
- Because it's like a
full day of rehearsal.
Like the day before,
and I'm just like trying
to learn like dance moves.
And I'm not a real dancer or singer,
so I'm like not in my--
- But that's what makes it awesome.
- It's what makes it fun.
- Yeah, you sell it.
That's the best part.
- Yeah.
Where I feel like me out there doing that
it gives like anyone hope.
(laughing)
- That's how I feel.
- It's just a guy out there who's mute,
he's like maybe I could.